okay I was actually going to start in
another 15 minutes but there's just way
too much news and I want to get two
phone calls and I want to get to all
sorts of stuff so I'm just going to get
going the the theme of this stream and
I'm sorry I didn't stream at all last
week on YouTube or twitch it was a crazy
week I was doing the show remotely and
it was just wacky wacky wacky but here I
am the theme of this stream is
impeachment is starting against
President Donald Trump we've been
wondering we've been going back and
forth but it for a very long time but
indeed it is time Nancy Pelosi has
announced a formal impeachment inquiry
of Donald Trump it's happening and we
have to talk about the goals we have to
talk about what would constitute a
successful impeachment because it's not
going to be removing Donald Trump from
office that's for sure
but it is indeed happening and things
are going to get very very crazy very
very quickly I first will just talk
about what's going on you can
communicate with me ask questions using
super chat at the bottom of the chat
window that dollar sign if we get 10
website members I will open up the phone
lines and look forward to hearing from
you and if we get 20 website members as
it says up there I will commit right
here and now to doing another stream
tomorrow so if you've been living under
a rock or not paying attention to the
news for the last two years which
actually sounds kind of nice in a way it
sounds refreshing there has been an
ongoing conversation about whether or
not Democrats are going to start
impeachment proceedings against
President Donald Trump and Nancy Pelosi
has announced today that indeed formal
impeachment inquiry of Trump will begin
now it's important to understand before
we look at the New York Times article
and I have a Reuters article as well
that I want to look at with you before
we even get into this stuff it's
extraordinarily important to understand
that this is a three step process the
decision that has been made so far is
merely to start an impeachment inquiry
the next step after such an inquiry
would be to decide whether the House
wants to move on to actually making the
case
for impeachment of Donald Trump the
house makes the case and then step three
would be the Senate voting on whether to
convict Donald Trump or not and of
course we have a Republican Senate and
they are not going to convict Donald
Trump they have actually shown that they
are brazenly and willfully going to
stand behind this president to a great
extent with some exceptions you know
Justin Amash and the Arizona senator
flake left but basically this is not
even a technique that should be measured
on the basis of whether it removes
Donald Trump before the November of 2020
election because it will not okay so
here is how I will evaluate the success
of this impeachment inquiry and
Democrats actually need to be very very
careful about this because this could
completely backfire on them the point of
this impeachment inquiry from my
perspective is to get damaging
information about Donald Trump out into
the public so that the November of Tony
Tony election will not go to Donald
Trump I don't see any path for the
actual removal via impeachment of Donald
Trump before November of 2020 because
Democrats don't control the Senate and
as a result there is a lot here that
Nancy Pelosi is going to have to manage
namely is this going to be turned around
on Democrats by Donald Trump as yet
another partisan witch hunt
just like the Russia probe because he
already laid the groundwork for it by
saying that this new Biden thing is
another witch hunt because Democrats
failed on Russia so now they're trying
Ukraine and the real risk here is that
it completely backfires on Democrats it
allows Donald Trump to paint himself as
the martyr as the victim and he is an
expert at doing that and he must not be
allowed to do that and that is why this
is the right move in the sense of
politically on the basis of what Donald
Trump has done how was this the tipping
point how have we come so far and we're
only now getting to an impeachment
inquiry
but at the same time it could easily
backfire on Democrats and I'm curious to
see actually I'm already seeing some
super chats on-screen including one from
Clayton can people see the super chat
okay if not I can make that bigger on
screen
I don't normally let's see I'll make it
a little bit bigger let me know if
that's tough to read because I am going
to be getting to these super chats for
sure anybody anybody oh the chat is very
very much delayed hmm that's weird I've
never seen the chat this delayed or you
can click on super chat to read it
yourself that's right yeah okay very
good
okay so I won't be worried about that
all right excellent so let's get into
the news that has broken here I do want
to say thanks to Matt holodeck Matt
holodeck has just signed up for a
membership on my website so that is new
member number one of the evening as I
mentioned if we get ten new members all
open phone lines and hear from you fine
folks and if we get 20 new members I
will guarantee to stream tomorrow more
incentive to to stream okay so let's
look at the New York Times report
Speaker Nancy Pelosi announced today
that the house will begin a formal
impeachment inquiry of President Trump
saying that he had betrayed his oath of
office and the nation's security and
seeking to enlist a foreign power for
his own political gain now already you
know the reality is that even if you
forget about the entire I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna get derailed here I'm not
but if you just ignore everything
russia-related
even just on Trump's support for the
Saudi war on Yemen
he was already impeachable arguably for
financial misdeeds Trump was already
impeachable so already you know I
understand that you have to make this
about I guess you have to make it about
one thing but maybe you don't because
there's much more actually that you
could impeach Donald Trump over okay
quote from Nancy Pelosi after emerging
from a meeting of House Democrats the
actions taken to date by the president
have seriously violated the Constitution
and Trump must be held accountable
no one is about above the law the
announcement was a stunning development
that unfolded after months of caution by
House Democrats who have been divided
over using the old
remedy to address what they have called
flagrant misconduct by the president it
had the potential to reshape mr. Trump's
presidency and to cleave an already
divided nation only a year before he
plans to stand for re-election in this
case with an avalanche of Democrats
including many who had resisted the move
now demanding it Ms Pelosi said mr.
Trump's reported actions and his
administration's refusal to share
details about the matter with Congress
have left the house no alternative
outside of impeachment I listen I've
said for months now impeach or don't
impeach or impeachment inquiry or no
impeachment inquiry I can understand
both I can understand that at this point
obviously there is more than enough
justification for an impeachment inquiry
I can also understand saying it's not
going to remove him before the election
let's just forget about it and focus our
energy on just simply defeating Donald
Trump without the inquiry but this is a
very important perspective which is the
house really has no alternative here the
right move the obvious move for the body
that is supposed to hold the president
accountable is to do an impeachment
inquiry we're not saying move to impeach
we're not saying vote in the Senate to
convict on impeachment
it's an abundantly clear case that can
be made for it's time for the inquiry
and that's all that's starting right
here by the way what what are people
talking about clickbait the impeachment
inquiry is starting Nancy Pelosi has
announced that there is a formal
impeachment inquiry of Donald Trump this
is step one of three of an impeachment I
don't know if it click calling things
clickbait is is genuinely like the most
milquetoast flaccid criticism that I've
ever seen
I had a debate once with a gentleman
named Carl Benjamin about it some of you
may know him if sargon of akkad about it
google search on my youtube channel for
the sargon clickbait debate and you will
see it is just a lame criticism you and
Marwick i want to say thank you to you
and Marwick who is the second new member
of the evening that is 2 out of 10 we're
20% of the way to me opening up the
phone lines and we are
percent of the way to me committing to
do a livestream tomorrow as well let's
continue at issue are allegations that
mr. Trump pressured the president of
Ukraine to open a corruption
investigation of former Vice President
Joe Biden a contender for the Democratic
nomination and his son the conversation
is said to be part of a whistleblower
complaint that the Trump administration
has withheld from Congress Trump said
today that he would authorize the
release of a transcript of the
conversation he's called it perfect etc
etc so listen there's so much
distraction going on here that we've got
to deal with this number one do the
conspiracy theory about Joe Biden is
laughable and I've got a video that's
going up on YouTube at let me see what
time this is happening at by the way
YouTube analytics seemed totally broken
and I don't know if anything's broken on
the public facing side I have a video
going up at 7:30 in a couple of hours in
detail debunking this stupid conspiracy
theory about Joe Biden the allegation is
Joe Biden's son worked for a Ukrainian
gas company the gas company was being
investigated
so Biden willy-nilly flies to Kiev and
tries to get this the the chief
prosecutor of Ukraine fired for
investigating his son the truth is this
is this was a chief prosecutor in
Ukraine that was under investigation for
corruption by multiple countries long
before Joe Biden got involved multiple
countries had already requested the
dismissal of that chief prosecutor and
Biden ended up being appointed point man
by Barack Obama relatively late in the
game and the conspiracy theory is
absolutely and completely laughable so
that's number one
number two the quote real story here
with all of the Ukraine thing that the
the important stories are not the
context of this transcript that Donald
Trump now is going to be releasing which
could be incomplete
we know the White
house doctors transcripts it could be it
could be a transcript that only
understanding prior conversations with
Ukraine would we understand the quid pro
quo that is being discussed the
transcript is not the issue there are
two issues here in only two issues
number one Donald Trump holding hostage
hundreds of millions of dollars of
military aid to a country if and until
they smear Joe Biden to help Trump win
in 2020 under the presumption that Biden
will be the nominee and that is not a
guarantee at this point in time and
number two that the whistleblower is
still being suppressed okay that has
taken a drastic backseat here and
yesterday on the program and I see the
super chats coming in folks and I'm
going to get to them next and there's
many of them the the that Donna I said
yesterday it's possible that the reason
that the White House is copping to some
of these allegations is that they've
calculated that something else would be
far worse for them and what that
something else may well be is the
whistleblower getting to talk because at
the heart of this is the suppression of
a whistleblower those are the two
primary things at issue here okay let me
say thanks to son to Kaka Ninh who is
the third new member of the evening that
gets us to three out of ten to open up
the phone lines and that gets us to
three out of 20 to get a commitment from
me to do another stream tomorrow if you
don't want me to stream tomorrow
definitely don't sign up the info is
right there oh and actually the website
is not totally visible let me shrink
that a little bit there we go
hopefully that's easier to see join
pakman.com is the website all right let
me look at some of these super chats and
see what's on people's minds alex
Saavedra with a dollar ninety-nine super
chat what will it take for Republicans
on this issue of Trump they're not going
to period and I would not hold my breath
for it Clayton Sackett with a $5 Super
chat do you believe this would D
illegitimate the Democrats if
this effort to impeach fails so the
answer is yes but what would we define
as a success and what I mean by that is
this impeachment effort this impeachment
inquiry is not going to remove Donald
Trump from the presidency the goal of
this impeachment inquiry should be in my
mind to generate news that will be in
the corporate news cycle to inform the
public about what Trump has done and the
idea would be that that would get people
to reconsider a vote for Trump in 2020
or it would get people who already don't
like the guy but weren't planning to
vote to get out and vote if the entire
impeachment inquiry is successfully
rebranded by Donald Trump as a
witch-hunt as you didn't get me on
Russia so you're gonna try to get me on
Ukraine if Trump makes himself the
martyr if Democrats missplay it it will
be devastating for Democrats there's no
other way to say it there's no other
what would I call it the the there
there's no other relevant analysis other
than this could deeply deeply backfire
on Democrats so absolutely we just need
to have the proper expectations which
are not that this is going to remove
Donald Trump sooner than we could vote
him out next super chet is from drew e 1
2 3 xx chromosome 10 abut not here I was
I wasn't born in the US so I cannot be
President Jimmy from Philly $2 super
chat Jimmy it's been so long since I've
heard from you I hope you're not drunk
impeach Trump Dems are morons can you
say backfire you know listen here's the
thing Jimmy is an angry I'm looking for
adjectives that but I don't want to go
overboard Jimmy isn't extraordinarily
angry and often misinformed trumpets but
Jimmy has done two things that I agree
with Jimmy is a paid member of the David
Pakman show
okay a trumpet is a paid member of the
show so that's just a sign that if you
actually like what I do Jimmy doesn't
even like it and he so
or it's it financially if you actually
like what I do please consider becoming
a member the info is over there but
you're right Jimmy this well could
backfire even though I think it's
completely justified and Democrats need
to be careful Brian Stephens what is the
probability impeachment occurs okay so
I'm sensing that folks are already
confused by this and this is a problem
that I've been trying to address this is
a three step process
okay the three steps are number one
impeachment probe impeachment inquiry
this is merely to figure out what has
taken place and get the information out
then Democrats could say we are arguing
for impeachment and there would be a
sort of trial by the house and step
three would be the Senate voting on
whether to remove Trump or not that last
step is not going to happen not as long
as Democrats don't control the Senate
Democrats don't control the Senate now
Democrats are not going to take over
control of the Senate in 2020 the
numbers just don't favor Democrats
Carlos Enriquez hey David
could this backfire on Republican swing
votes in 2020 you know with his 80 plus
percent approval rating at all getting a
lot of questions about this this could
backfire and I hope Nancy Pelosi manages
it correctly let me say thanks to David
I don't know if the last name is
pronounced ray Oh David Roe Rolt David
is definitely the first name David is
new member number four of the evening
that gets us 40% of the way to opening
the phone lines and 20% of the way to me
doing another live stream tomorrow I
invite you to support this channel
YouTube by the way if you saw my video
yesterday YouTube now has formalized the
ways in which they are screwing
independent news and politics producers
like me so we are effectively having to
write off YouTube revenue as a reliable
source of revenue for what we do so
we're increasingly relying on website
memberships join pakman.com is the place
to sign up I promise it's painless and
there's a coupon code there that'll save
you money and I'll save say your name
and I will also potentially take some
phone calls so sign up and I'll keep
saying hello to people
Gregory Magor Shaq with a $20 super chat
the high-water mark for the evening
Gregory says impeachment is small beans
compared to deploying troops to Saudi
Arabia I feel sorry for the Persian
people unless they remove ayatollahs
regime I am worried that a war will
begin before 2020 and destroy the entire
region I'm not quite as hyperbolically
pessimistic as you Gregory but I was
doing everything I was imploring
corporate media yesterday to cover the
troops deployed to Saudi Arabia more
than they have because it is a major
story horror fan for life whoa
they just shot down let me see here let
me go horror fan for life great to hear
this profound and beautiful news yeah
Billy Vanilli our Democrats over
analyzing the situation what if it
backfires Republicans impeached over a
bj and Bush still won put some light on
his crimes do you have a guessing you
mean Clinton right or Bush one after
Clinton served two terms not sure I
understand that cat purple you should
talk to Kyle on secular talk then
because he isn't laughing and has a much
clearer take on it I don't know what you
mean laughing about what I'm not sure I
know what you mean
Christopher Bartram isn't there a small
chance Republicans in the Senate will
want to be on the right side of history
in the face of overwhelming evidence no
I mean okay listen there is always a
chance it's a there's a nonzero chance
that Republicans might say we are going
to vote to convict and remove Trump but
it's very close to zero they've they've
proven that still do Bell says or doable
I'm not sure how to pronounce that $8
super chat thanks for everything you do
David that was a fine-looking pepper too
yeah if you don't follow me on instagram
there is a 13 second video that's it
it's 13 seconds out of your day I'm
David Pakman on Instagram of me picking
I'm looking at it now I'm picking my
first pepper from my pepper plant of the
entire season I know it's almost October
and I try the pepper on the video and I
didn't even notice this because I'm just
so used to it but at my
there are constant birds screeching in
the background you can barely even hear
what I'm saying over the screeching
birds and I'm so numb to it because I'm
so used to it I didn't even notice it
and a bunch of people in the comments
point out that like do I have a hawk or
something or am I in a VA an aviary is
that what it's called in any case that's
my latest post on Instagram at David
Pakman and there I have a second pepper
I will be harvesting tomorrow as well
Dan of Earth says do you think
impeachment hearings will negatively
impact Trump or embolden his base even
more yet that's the question and as I
said if Donald Trump can turn
impeachment around in - oh poor Trump
it's a witch hunt I'm the victim nobody
you know presidential harassment all
that stuff and in fact I kind of want to
pull up Donald Trump's let's see real
Donald Trump let's look at Donald
Trump's Twitter page just to see if he's
tweeted anything 15 minutes
Pompeyo has permission to release the
transcript presidential harassment one
hour ago
they never even saw the transcript of
the call a total witch hunt Pelosi
Nadler Schiff and of course Maxine
Waters okay yeah so he's going with John
all right very very clear Trump is just
going witch-hunt fully fully going which
I'm there so that's what's gonna go on
and that may actually work let me thank
just a couple of more people here San
Juan eat delicious or as non
Argentinians would say Reyes and Nick
slob ah or slab off I'm not exactly sure
how it's pronounced to new members that
gets us to six out of ten on the website
and that gets us to six out of 20 for me
doing a stream tomorrow or apologies
we're 60% of the way to opening the
phone lines and 30% of the way to me
committing to doing another stream
tomorrow a thong tah with a five
Canadian dollar super chat saying this
is a test it's a successful one I would
consider it for sure
car wash freak 97 sends a 99 cent super
chat with noah quest
in her comment Kaylee Bracken's what
makes you think the Dems will actually
go through with anything around
impeachment sorry I joined late well
it's been announced Kaylee so Nancy
Pelosi has ordered an impeachment probe
okay so the inquiry is starting formally
the question which maybe you're asking
is whether Democrats will go through
with actually recommending impeachment
and doing the impeachment trial but the
inquiry is happening SC bi with a 10
euro super chat hi Kyle kolinsky said
the story about Biden is true and
Democrats are hypocrites because also
Hill II went to other countries to find
stuff on Trump do you agree I I don't
know I have to see what you're talking
about
AJ gray hi David how far can Trump go to
undermine the Democrats even during an
impeachment inquiry very far and this is
a concern this isn't completely a
concern the hang G what are your
thoughts on yang at 8 percent nationally
all right I will briefly take a break
from impeachment stuff to look at that I
did not see yang at 8 percent let's see
here
yang Emerson oh okay very interesting
okay hold on I just got some kind of add
here Emerson poll has yang at 8
nationally so listen I think the same
thing about yang at 8 nationally that I
think about it's funny I looked at just
Biden Warren Sanders in this poll
earlier and I thought that the numbers
didn't look right so even without seeing
yang at 8 I already was skeptical of
this poll I simply don't believe that
there is a statistical three-way tie
right now between Biden Warren and
Sanders this is by far the lowest that
Biden has pulled in any poll and
remember I'm not voting for Biden in the
primary I'm a progressive period okay
this is not anything other than me
reading this I don't buy that Biden has
dropped this much and I don't think that
Warren and Sanders are statistically
tied so in the same way I have trouble
believing that yang is really at 8
nationally but if two more polls come
out and they have similar numbers then I
will have no choice but to consider
at least potentially valid ORSA muldowr
sends a dollar ninety-nine Thank You G
nine one six if the House votes yes
could Mitch prevent any vote slash
discussion or would Senate be forced to
vote yea or nay you know I believe that
if the house it's not the house of
voting YES if the house brings charges I
believe that the Senate has to vote on
them that that's my boy at what I'm what
I think is the situation Brandon getter
asks does impeaching a president stop
them from being elected again if not
then what does impeachment actually do
besides raise awareness of the crime and
in peace so again understand all we have
is an impeachment inquiry that's all an
impeachment inquiry does not prevent a
president from being reelected if we get
to impeachment charges those would also
not prevent the president from being
reelected if Donald Trump is impeached
and convicted by the Senate and removed
my understanding is he would not be
eligible for re-election
Nick s backfire is a Republican talking
point does the law not matter no it does
matter Nick and in fact what I'm
pointing out is I believe that there
were viable Democratic strategies for
removing Trump in 2020 that included an
impeachment inquiry and that did not my
only concern the backfire I'm talking
about is not a backfire because there's
anything unwarranted about the inquiry
the only backfire I'm talking about is
establishment Democrats are great at
just self-destructing and I am not
convinced that they are going to manage
this in a way that it does not backfire
Zachary Anderson and Christopher Taylor
have become new YouTube members which I
appreciate
Eddie ex-gay can we still get Pelosi out
in 2020 yeah
listen if she leads an impeachment
inquiry that helps to get Donald Trump
out in 2020 my sense is she's gonna be
in in 2020 okay let me say thanks to a
couple of other people here members are
just flying in let me see here okay so I
said thanks to Nick already Aiden
mccallion thank you
for being a new david pakman show member
I appreciate it
William blankly thank you for being a
new david pakman show member Melissa
Jacobson is a new David Pakman show
member Jose Vasquez is a new David
Pakman show member and Kevin Kovac Kovac
Kovac is a new david pakman show member
that is five more that gets us to 11 new
website members which puts us where we
need to be to open the phone lines and I
will do that in a little bit and it puts
us just more than halfway to me
committing to stream tomorrow I've been
getting so many messages from people
complaining that I'm just not streaming
enough and they said what you should do
is make the membership challenge that
you will commit to stream the next day
and that's what I'm doing if we get to
20 I will stream tomorrow
and I want to also say thanks to Sean
Akutagawa who has signed up and that
gets us to 12 for the evening which is
just delightful 12 is a great number
there it is 12 all right very good okay
let me do a couple other super chats
here by the way welcome if you're just
coming across my channel if you've never
been here before
please please please consider
subscribing to my youtube channel
youtube has now completely deprioritized
us in the algorithm and unfortunately
what that has done is it is slowing down
our views it is slowing down our the
number of new subscribers that we're
getting daily YouTube is really screwing
independent producers so if you're new
here at minimum hit that subscribe
button there will be many streams as the
impeachment of Donald Trump gets going
Joseph Thompson this must be a good day
and it's about time it is about time
whether it's good will depend on how
it's handled
Rolando wind-borne has signed up on
YouTube thank you Zachary Anderson sends
a dollar super chop Shaun Lord oh could
this situation end up helping Joe
Biden's campaign yeah I actually said
this on the broadcast show today one of
the unintended consequences of what
Donald Trump is trying to do or is doing
withholding 250 million dollars from
Ukraine
if and until ukraine smears Biden I
don't know what it would do if Biden is
the nominee in a general election but
I'm convinced that this is going to help
Biden in the primary and my prediction
is that next week polling will reflect
that rufus evans has signed up on
youtube thank you
Rolando Wilborn says if you're Nancy how
do you handle the impeachment
proceedings well I number one I stop the
hyperbole and keep things not
compartmentalized but go only as far as
where the facts take you right now she
has done the right thing which is she
has said what we know right now
unquestionably without a doubt supports
an impeachment inquiry and that's what
we're doing next and during the process
just go through the impeachment inquiry
without saying anything about the next
steps let the information bring
everybody to the conclusion rather than
assuming it on the way in ok composite
says if the Ukraine call sorry about
that
if the Ukraine call is the focus of
impeachment and it turns out the Biden's
really did have cover-up dealings in
Ukraine we are toast
absolutely if but again I've seen no
evidence of that
Jackson David you need to stop reading
YouTube comments nothing of value there
judge reception by like / dislike stop
giving disclaimers love the show yeah
listen I read very few YouTube comments
because it is a toxic cesspool of the
worst of the worst of the worst but even
looking at likes dislikes is not a great
barometer because sometimes our videos
will get brigaded when you know someone
like I won't even name anybody but other
people will sometimes do videos about my
videos and then they send just a
rational bunch of followers to dislike
my video so even that is not necessarily
the right the right barometer the dude
used to be a Tulsi fan but her recent
Rubin showing and now impeachment
responds got a say David your misgivings
were correct I don't know what Tulsi
said about impeachment let's see what
she said Tulsi a Democrat tells he tell
seek avert won't join fellow Democrats
calls for impeachment
the hell out of here I mean did I just
have no no page that what is she polling
she's pulling one okay she pulled zero
and if Fox News get get out of here ID
who cares it's just so so it's like okay
hey you know what Tom Steyer has this or
that because it wow steyr Gabbard give
me a break
okay Dave Lendl with a dollar 69 super
chat thank u rxw tendencies hey David I
was the caller who questions some of the
motives behind progressives coverage of
far-right pundits would love to continue
the conversation all right oh let's
let's do that sometime
Armando odd alcohol Chiba do they
lobbied do you think Matty and if so do
you have a special Gordon now I never
got into Monty I know that you know what
kind of an Argentinian am i if I don't
drink Matt did but I've just never liked
it charm Anders says Bernie is down in
New Hampshire he won by 23 in 2016
sad I've covered that and that is not
the best sign for Bernie dusty Dark
Horse how soon can we expect the polls
to move I think by early next week we
will have polls that reflect the initial
reaction to the impeachment inquiry as
well as in the Democratic primary
initial reaction to the Biden conspiracy
theories which is what I see them as
right now it's just me me says hey keep
it up David I truly appreciate your
fight Michael wheeler who are you
currently endorsing for president
whoever is the Democratic nominee but
I'm a Bernie Warren guy myself Jason
Smith with a $20 super chat word is
Democrats are getting evidence of money
laundering from Deutsche Bank and
mizar's
the evidence against Trump will be so
compelling that the Senate will have no
choice but to move forward or risk
losing seats what is your thought have
not yet read that would be absolutely
delightful but I will I will research
that the largest super chat of the
evening $49.99 is coming up next but
before I get to that let me do a couple
of other new member welcome sunny
Ferguson is a new david pakman show
member using that info signed up on my
web site
joe shannon is a new david pakman show
frederik Toulon is a new David Pakman
show member David Schultz is a new David
Pakman show member Robert Brophy is a
new david pakman show member and let me
see if I missed anybody here and Kyle
Mizrahi is a new david pakman show
member that gets me caught up that is
six more and that gets us to 18 for the
evening wow this is a strong show you
know the other night when I did a live
stream of the third democratic debate we
had like 40 for new members which was a
record for any live stream and 18 is a
very very solid showing so we'll get the
phone lines opened up in a little bit
Christopher Smith 49.99 the most
generous super chat of the evening I
really appreciate all the hard work you
put into your channel and your research
people like you helped solidify
Republicans are never going to change
because they would rather eat their own
young to make sure team red always wins
there's a lot of just like checking
boxes and seeing politics a sport on
both sides but it's way worse with
Republicans I mean listen when when we
had that story of a Republican being
caught on a recording with a list of
other Texas Republicans that should be
primary and there was a huge cover-up by
Republicans because they thought it was
so damaging they didn't want the
recording getting out that happened on
the Democratic side you would have left
us saying somebody's doing that let's
release it let's get it out in the open
and let's get the person out of here
because this person is toxic Republicans
instead want to cover up and it's just a
sport for them you're completely right
Anabelle the paladin says if trump or
any president gets removed from office
by impeachment is there a law in place
to prevent them from running again I
don't know the answer to that I don't
know the answer to that for whatever
reason I'm assuming there is but I don't
know the answer to that Chris parks
thanks for signing up on YouTube
appreciate that Tyler Bale asks what are
the odds of Democrats winning 2020 in
spite of any negative consequences of
the inquiry well I don't know odds but
this
the whole point if Trump successfully
plays the victim card then he may be
able to use the impeachment inquiry to
his benefit in 2020 Donald J Trump is
here low unemployment and business
optimism is high make America great
again
hope that was worth $2 Donny boy Drako
Rosso says will China be emboldened by
impeachment against Hong Kong I don't
have any particular reason to think that
that's a direct causal thing but it's an
interesting question Jackson look at the
typical amount of likes and dislikes if
a video gets brigaded likes will be the
same but dislikes will be huge if likes
are less than normal it's a bad video ok
take my word it's a little more
complicated than that but I appreciate
the idea John Connor says please support
the Venus Project it is true change
Daniel Krieger says you and Kyle
kolinsky should debate about something
Alexander Padilla says who has hurt the
country more george w bush or donald
trump that is really difficult to say
yeah I I mean it's it's different times
of her different kinds of hurt I would
say Chad durka wits says you think this
reelecting him from Phoenix Arizona not
sure what you mean Chad Adam munos is a
new member on YouTube rad Willy 1 asks I
disagree that it's a conspiracy Biden's
son was on the board of a Ukrainian
Power Company why okay check out my
video in a couple of hours Harrison G
has signed up on YouTube Rolando
wind-borne are you going to do a video
on greta's speech not probably not to be
perfectly honest but I talked about it
on the members only bonus show today
Charmander char Mandor says any proof
that Burnie can win the Rust Belt vs.
Trump now there's no proof than anything
can listen there's no proof that
anything will happen but there's plenty
of evidence that it could happen based
on the polling that we're seeing
Brendan getter says where do you get
your news from who do you watch on
YouTube I basically read I barely watch
any TV
newse I don't watch any YouTube news
I've never seen a lot of the shows that
I think people who watch my show watch I
just read and on YouTube I mostly watch
honestly I mostly watch chess streamers
and what else do I watch on YouTube
I'll watch like concert videos for bands
that I like but that's basically it
Shaun King says do you think there could
be a deal made behind closed doors of
Crump resigns pence will pardon like
Nixon Ford who do you prefer Trump or
pence so yeah that's certainly something
that could happen and at this point you
know pence would definitely be less
scandal-ridden than Trump but Trump's
doing real damage at this point so I
find it they just both need to go that's
the reality
Gregory Magor Shaq says David I built a
solution that would greatly help you
make reliable revenue after the YouTube
changes please try to remember to add me
back on Facebook after the show I would
like to discuss yeah I don't do any of
that stuff via Facebook and also I'm at
my limit of Facebook friends so the best
thing would be to email me Gregory thank
you okay let me welcome camille Konopka
who is a new david pakman show member I
very much appreciate that that gets us
to 19 way more than our target of 10 to
open the phone lines and just one member
shy of 20 if we get to 20 members I said
I would I would do another stream
tomorrow sam-i-am
asks it's possible to impeach McConnell
over what I would be the question Gallic
Hills says how does impeachment appear
to other countries I think to most
countries it appears as extremely
overdue Patrick Henry asks is Bernie our
last chance to take down the
establishment I've never seen a
candidate quite like him bernie is
something else for sure but I think it's
important to remember that there are
numerous people running in the 2020
Democratic primary who would be by far
the most progressive presidents of the
United States if they were to win
Chadd Dirk oh it says do you think
impeaching will energize the Republican
Party it may very well the question is
what is revealed through the impeachment
inquiry John Connor David can you please
interview Peter Joseph from the
zeitgeist movement again maybe maybe
he's been on but it's been a little
while
daft Brett says hey David loved the show
mo Bamba or sicko mode I have no idea
what that is sounds like a video game
thing
Harrison G says I'd love to hear your
take on a potential libertarian wave
establishment Republicans have been
resilient I see potential if impeachment
proceeds I have a hard time imagining
there will be such a such a libertarian
wave hello David mr. rag dollar asks I
was curious to know if you support the
cause cheers your friend large soda I
don't know what cause you're referring
to my friend Alex Billings says it's
time Pelosi took some action she's been
killing the Dems AOC has been calling
for this for a long time looking forward
to 2028 it's a long time from now that
is a very long time from now
let's see here young dumb and baroque
says does McConnell have any means to
block impeachment hearings from reaching
the Senate once we get there I believe
the answer is no Steve Ernst Keyes I'm a
first year first grade teacher who do
you believe will do more for our
teachers nationally but Bernie or Warren
I don't know enough about their
positions on teachers to be able to say
for sure they would both be a drastic
improvement over what we have right now
a nincompoop 25 says rate your top five
chess youtubers so let's see I like I
like Eric Rosen I watch hikaru although
I find his streams less instructive than
Eric's I like watching Ben Feingold
although I don't fully understand why he
like is he playing deliberately poorly
sometimes or or not or is it is he just
not quite so good in some cases so the
three of them I like who else kind of
think who else I like I don't know those
are the three I would say I watched the
most probably gr has arrived gr
market packed easy if you aren't ready
yet market later on write it down either
way because it is not going away I think
you know that love gr okay the tag der
is a new member
Danube ian says here we go it's
happening Matt Chavez says jobs lost due
to Medicare for all what is Bernie's
plan I've addressed this check out the
video on my channel Paul a tradie says
great stream keep it up PS rest in peace
boogie2988 died I'm sorry I don't know
who that is but I'm sorry to hear that
as well I want to say thanks to sunny
Greco who is new member number 20 of the
evening thank you so much and I want to
also read this super chat from sly one
music who says hey Dave big fan and
member do you think the scandal will
boost Biden in the polls I believe that
it actually will yeah I made that
commentary earlier today a wlq says I've
heard critics of Bernie's Wall Street
speculation tax say that Sweden
implemented a similar tax in the 1980s
really unsuccessful
love to whoa did every my entire thing
just froze there briefly I hope other
people's uh that everybody's video
freeze that was weird no it didn't
freeze okay you know that was weird I
it's very popular to say that everything
has backfired on Sweden but it's not
true and I'd have to look at it in more
detail
Brian Stephen says that that boogie
person did not die and it's a false
rumor III apologize I don't know
anything about it Justin Quran says as
big news as impeachment is the fact that
on the world stage an American president
refused to defend the journalist was
truly frightening for journalists around
the world of course of course I've been
talking about that for a long time okay
on that note let's do phone calls the
phone number is six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty but let's
see do we want to do it right now yeah I
guess we'll do it I guess we can get set
up for it right now let me do that
we'll get pulled up so tomorrow stream
by the way we have gotten to enough whoa
that was weird
we've gotten to enough new members that
I am going to be doing another live
stream tomorrow tomorrow night's
livestream will be on Twitch okay so
please make sure that you're following
me at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
because tomorrow's tomorrow night's
livestream is going to be on Twitch did
someone say my entire life stream is
gone now no I don't think so
okay all right very good so six one
seven eight three eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let me get
myself connected and then give you a few
guidelines for the phone calls calling
in to the David Pakman show please do
not use speakerphone have your question
ready and listen for David to call out
your area code alright here we go
so we are going to go oh I do need to
make sure I'm taking notes about all of
the callers this is we ended we actually
now have a scoring system if you if
people only knew the things that we're
going
behind the scenes here we now have a
scoring system for callers it's been
formalized so I keep track of every
caller and everybody gets a score and
the score affects how likely I am to
pick up on you in the future so I'm
gonna start going through phone calls
based on notes that I have about callers
and all sorts of different things but
that being said if you sign up on my oh
by the way yeah the super chat check out
a god Matt or yeah I watch him as well
he's really really good okay let me just
make sure I don't get ahead of myself
here all right so if you become a member
and you want to get right on let me know
somehow maybe be a super shot what your
area code is and then I can expedite
getting you on all right it's been four
months since we heard from him
let's go first to Jimmy from Philly to
see what's on his mind Jimmy it's been
so long what's going on anybody it's
been long because you're not advertising
your your call-in shows on YouTube no
that's not true every time we go live
there is a notification that goes out if
you are signed up to the notifications
David yeah I used to get the
notifications now I'm not getting them
that's your problem so here look I'm
holding up there it is david pakman show
is live now so I'm holding up for the
audio no no I got this one obviously
that's why I'm here but I don't get any
other call it is there either we're all
it's not live so this is very meta so if
we can talk about the live call shows or
you can maybe ask a question or make a
comment to I can ask a question you're
actually going to answer in that guest
lately what do you think about that this
whole impeachment thing is don't you
think that I mean common sense says it's
gonna hurt the debts they got nothing to
impeach them for well I don't agree with
that but where I do maybe CIA I with you
Jimmy is that there is a risk here that
it backfires on Democrats and I want to
be really clear you're saying it's gonna
backfire on Democrats I think because
you're saying there's nothing impeach a
bull is that correct correct yeah I
it could backfire on Democrats because
Donald Trump is very good at self
victimizing and downplaying what is in
the news evidence then he slipped me
impeached right well that's why we're
held and am playing all that ain't gonna
matter well we will see how the inquiry
goes then I mean that that's might be
honest there's real evidence to impeach
him yeah and impeach of course they'll
be acquitted in the Senate everyone
knows that I agree with you did a
Republican Senate is not going to
convict him there's no question right
just like they didn't convicting and
claim was guilty as hell Clinton white
and he any obstructed justice he tried
to get that girl to testify a certain
way Jimmy are you more than Arkansas you
sound lucid this evening are you
drinking no not at all I don't drink as
much David because I do LSD every
weekend and it helps me you know I can
notice you you are noticeably more lucid
than when you've called in drunk so I
appreciate that Jimmy
well even or not psychedelics help you
yeah what do they help you do I don't
know I just did you know whereas before
I would go an impulse go buy some beers
now I think about and say yeah I'm
really need that effect can kind of
control before yeah I don't know alright
very good Jimmy and his landscaping
slowing down now that we're getting into
the colder season slightly will be don't
leave soon good very good
do you advise me let me get some advice
from you Jimmy do you advise me to rake
my leaves in batches as they come down
to avoid having to do it all at once or
do you recommend letting them all fall
and then doing it in one shot well
firstly David I doubt that you're gonna
rake you're gonna hire somebody both no
I read I read my only i rake my own
leaves thing well depending like like if
we have a house with 50 trees yeah we'll
do it three or four times but evenly
spaced like every two weeks genius but
if it's a house with not much we might
wait to the end of the year but
generally you should rake them up
because certain leaves are acidic and
can mess up your lawn so
you know I mean once you get a covering
every 10 days or so you can do it but if
I could back back flower baby makes it
easy oh yeah I don't have I'm those
gas-powered I don't want any gas powered
tools yeah I only do elected I don't
want to keep gas around the house yeah
well you could you you could probably
buy a decent electric backpack I don't
know but backpacks the way to go I mean
you don't even have to rate David you
know even though the rake you just blow
it very good
alright Jimmy thank you so much
appreciate the phone call thank you have
a good one
very good all right Jesse I can have
reasonable conversations with whoever
that is that is proof of it for sure
let's go next to our caller to the nine
seven from the nine seven eight area
code who's calling today from nine seven
eight my name is Haley Oh what's going
on but I was actually that called in and
you did the video about the progressive
youtubers okay very good
I'm glad to have you are on the phone so
yeah no I wanted to make it clear
definitely don't take any issue with
independent youtubers are you know
making a profit off of exposing bad
ideas it was really just the the fact
that like you sometimes Sam's leader etc
those people that are named bring like
like for example when Ben Shapiro says
the thing about Brett Kavanaugh is like
that whole thing like that something
like that is it needed to be discussed
it's not something that brings value I
think sort of viewers it's just Ben
Shapiro saying something you know and
I'm sure you find what I'm talking about
with his most recent statement yeah so
Leo you're taking issue with my story
choice it sounds like I more so bad and
progressive youtubers and generalize see
they'll cover maybe Candace Owen says
something that's very outlandish or
steven crowder yes better and it's like
what what helps these people get so big
is the constant coverage of them and I
think it'd be better if cuz I like you
know you guys I you know I've subscribed
to your channel and stuff so it's not
that I don't like what you guys do it's
just that I think it'd be better if you
guys didn't just
bring today's they need that attention
those people and that's what gets them
so big mildly milo i annapolis whoever
it might be
uh-huh fry bought that attention and i
think it would be better to not give it
to them i guess is my point okay yeah i
mean if that's a perfectly reasonable
position to take and you you know i
we've made a calculation that there is
benefit in the net - occasionally
covering what some of these people say
but different different people can
certainly disagree not yeah i guess so i
I just saw are you familiar I don't know
if you're familiar with our contra
points have you ever had a Natalie wind
to the youth Luba on the Left I have
interviewed her on my show and the
interview did very very well
oh you have yeah I'll to check that out
when I was in CQC I think she does a
good job at exposing some of those
already far-right ideas that kind of
brings some value rather than just kind
of and I'm not saying I'm not saying you
guys don't bring value I'm just saying
at times when you guys discuss you know
whether beastie McCloud has said
something or whatever it's a controversy
might be it's not needed to have a video
good there's always a video whether he
listen I think you're getting leo III
Wilson love I think you're getting a
little bit presumptuous by being the
person who determines what isn't isn't
of value something may not be up your
alley right but certainly you know if
you prefer contra points video essay
style thing then catching up on what's
going on in the news and some of the
wacky things that right winger said then
you you can choose that but you know to
start determining what is and isn't a
value it's like saying this music is
objectively better than that music I
mean it's a matter of taste right yeah
but we can clearly see that the constant
coverage of these people is what's
gotten them to the point where they're
at in their career I don't think they'd
be well off I think what's gotten them
to what they are in their career is the
fact that the right loves to rally
around the personality of some of these
clowns in a way that the left does not
and it allows these grifters to build a
cult of personality around themselves I
don't think it's the left for taking
their ideas that has pushed them into
the into the limelight I just disagree
yeah I don't think it's that's I think
it's maybe a bit of bowls I don't think
it's necessarily one thing or the other
necessarily I definitely think you're
right about you know that they circle
around these grifters and I think part
of they're part of the way that they get
so big also though I think it
contributes 5 Ewing videos that just
bring constant attention but clearly you
know we've obviously disagreed
all right Leo very good I appreciate you
disagreeing respectfully and I hope to
hear from you again thank you very much
let me say thank you to oh hold on it
just so no there is not a new member
okay so I'm gonna do Super chats and
take more calls just a reminder if
you're new here
make sure you've hit the subscribe
button and you're subscribed to my
youtube channel I really appreciate when
people do that we're trying to get to a
million subscribers although YouTube is
certainly making it difficult enough the
primary source of funding for our show
for everything we do our website
memberships join pakman.com is the
website 20 people have signed up tonight
and that has gotten us to open the phone
lines and it has also gotten us for me
it's gotten me to commit to doing
another stream tomorrow night which will
be on twitch at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman by all means please keep those
memberships coming and I'll keep
thanking folks let me do a couple of
other super chats rhetorical oracle
sends a $2 super chat Michael wheeler
says can you do a POTUS poll right here
now I don't know what you mean
and I'm not sure how I could do a poll
right now Kyle clues says a 1cc 7
judgment in cases of impeachment shall
not extend further than to removal from
office and disqualification to hold and
enjoy any office of honor trust or
profit under the United States there it
is if you are impeached you can't run
again and Rai minders okay right minders
suggested a god matter for chess
commentary he's really really good
should Bernie supporters speak more
about how Warren will take PAC money in
the general by all means if they think
that that is a good argument against
Warren then they should use it to their
advantage coupage says Libby soy boys
don't rake their own leaves well I must
not be a Libby SOI boy then jour be
blurb e says 8:28 Oh jour be blurb e is
the
from eight to eight and but the thing is
I don't know what I don't know that you
remember and I also don't actually see
any callers from eight to eight eight to
eight on the hold right now that's weird
Rob Z says tell C qualified for what oh
I guess the third debate fourth debate
jor B blur B is a new YouTube member
okay all right there it is and I see
eight to eight all right eight to eight
you are on live what's going on eight to
eight
that's me correct yes it is hi I have a
lot of things that I'd like to ask you
but since you have limited time since
the Senate is clearly the biggest
obstacle towards some framing from the
Justice and the scientific obstacle to a
lot of things what do you think the best
strategy is be a certain selection of
states or a certain approach what's the
best what is the best strategy to take
the Senate in 2020 or if need be 2022 so
that we can get this issue out of the
way I don't see any strategy that will
get Democrats the Senate in 2020 and I
think the strategy in 2022 is to just
run good campaigns I mean what you have
to understand about the Senate is that
because there are a hundred seats
one-third of which are up for reelection
every election cycle there is sort of
like a systemic bias that either favors
Democrats or favors Republicans and I've
not seen any credible path for Democrats
to take over the Senate in 2020 I'm not
saying we shouldn't try every single you
got to fight every single election but I
just don't see it so then it's just a
matter of coming in in 2022 hopefully
with the Democratic president and
working to take it over then and if I
could just have a quick follow-up for
that oh yeah just just one suggestion
for 2022 what what would be one example
of a solid campaign strategy
specifically in a state that is not
necessarily state either not necessarily
safe or that seems like you could be
vulnerable it I know that Montana comes
to mind because sometimes yeah it's just
it's two it's three years away with the
the strategy that makes sense in 2022 is
in great part going to be influenced by
was Donald Trump reelected or was Donald
Trump not real
so it's it's so difficult to say at this
point yeah okay fair enough
well thank you for taking my question
all right appreciate it thank you so
much let me say thanks to Brandon ransom
Brandon ransom is the 21st new member of
the evening on my website really
appreciate that Brandon and I also want
to say thanks to oh wait there's one
more here I also want to say thanks to
Adam Weiner who is new member number
twenty-two of the evening it's shaping
up to be a very very solid solid stream
let's see here is there anything else
Jimmy from Philly says didn't contra
points get bounced from YouTube I've no
reason to think that forbidden fruit
basket says shout out to my buddy Sahil
aka progressive voice tristan McCoy says
this is Tristan from Casey mo what is
the number the number is six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty and
on that note let's go next to the caller
from the 208 area code who's calling
today from 2:08 hello David this is
Spencer hey Spencer what's going on yeah
just quick question and sorry if you
answered this earlier I mainly just
curious what is the like parameters of
the impeachment inquiry like what kind
of things can are they going to be
investigating well the as it's been
announced and I can even put it up on
the screen here the probe centers on
whether Trump abused his presidential
powers and sought help from a foreign
government for his re-election visa V
the Ukraine Biden Fiasco so as as
announced that will be the focus of the
inquiry okay and it can't extend beyond
that that's a good question because you
know I think that Yemen should be on the
table I think financial stuff should be
on the table I don't know I don't know
whether they have to delineate that
ahead of time in this way okay yeah
thanks for taking my call I really
appreciate what you do I watch your show
I'm a number also one last thing what is
your favorite movie oh I don't know I
mean I don't know I did there's there's
so many movies I couldn't but it's like
saying what's my favorite book I've read
five in the last month
than two of them are really great and
it's so hard to say I never think in
superlatives in that way then then I
guess I'll say you should add like a
movie or two in your book recommendation
segment
you know I barely watch movies the last
movie I watched I think was I think it
was in Bruges right before I went to
Belgium and that's like a yeah alright
Spencer thank you for the call
appreciate it very much
RJ Duarte has signed up on YouTube which
I very much appreciate Joanna Corvinus
says Pelosi certainly took her effing
time eighty-six forty-five black and
sprite hey David just sending some
appreciation really I like your corner
sofa
thanks for everything keep it up Rick
Park has also signed up I'm not going to
do any more boogie stuff because I just
don't understand it Lewis gross is a new
member on YouTube
rhetorical Oracle says if Bernie wins
the nomination will the DNC scuttle many
general election efforts or that they
would ultimately align behind him
relatively painlessly they will
eventually get behind him although maybe
reluctantly slow so for the
establishment for sure let me say thanks
to we have a new $25 patron Christopher
McCann I'm gonna count it to our number
of new members I want to say thanks to
Joshua Wilson who just signed up on my
website I want to say thanks to Jay
Lemoore who just signed up on my website
and I think there's one more here and I
want to say thanks to Howard books balm
who has signed up on my website that is
for new members that gets us to 26
we have blown out of the water the
initial goal of 10 and we're actually
crushing the goal of 20 which gets us
another live stream tomorrow evening
let's go to somebody else let's go to
where do we want to go you know I have a
note that Sam from 202 is an interesting
caller Sam what's going on hi isn't me
that is you okay I want to say two
things number one do you think the
Republic
party you know how the Republican Party
and the Democratic Party it changed even
though it took like 30 years beginning
with FDR then ending with Nixon yes okay
yeah that's to a certain extent it's
really quite do you think yeah but the
alignment was more complicated than that
but that being said I still look I'm
curious what the question is on that
basis the Kure is a question is because
it do you think Trump is the beginning
of the parties becoming totally alien to
what they were say in 2000 i don't know
that trump is necessary and we're
terrible at predicting the future so you
may be completely right Sam I don't have
reason to believe right now that Trump
is going to cause a restructuring of the
Democratic Party I think that it's the
progressive movement within the
Democratic Party that may modify the
Democratic Party I do believe it is
plausible and I don't know how likely
that Donald Trump is going to cause a
rift within the Republican Party that it
will either effectively become two
parties or be forced into restructuring
but I so yes I think more on one side
than the other what you're saying is
plausible also I did a lot of research I
did a huge google type on I have another
book recommendation I'll get to that a
second
I did a huge Google Drive on
Scandinavian history and like how they
got to where they are now like with
their socialism oh why not
it took about 70 years to go from I'm
not saying the United States is where
they were at the end of World War two
but at the end of World War two remember
Denmark had nothing they blew up their
boats so Hitler couldn't use them and
everybody won but it I think it would
take 50 years to get Sanders proposals
done well what is he what would you as a
progressive today to that well my
question is which
what socialist countries are you talking
about in Scandinavia I'm talking about
the Scandinavian countries like Denmark
Sweden like how they have reached out
their free health care although all that
stuff that didn't come overnight
right but they're not that's not
socialism I'm talking about I'm talking
about democratic socialism um so I mean
social democracy right social
yeah yeah yeah capitalism but with a
huge welfare suit yeah listen these
things are a process I don't know it's
in general people overestimate what they
can do in a day and underestimate what
they can do in a year I think that that
is generally an accurate thing so I
don't pretend to know how long some of
these big reforms will take but
something like Medicare for all for
example is going to be a process and the
beginning is going to be having a
president who is for those things but
that is just the beginning right and by
the way I have a book recommendation for
you stop me if you've heard about it yes
called the dead zone by Stephen King
it's based this guy the main character
in it is basically if Trump was actually
smart that's what his nickname should be
okay
I've not I'm not familiar with that one
I recently read my first Stephen King
novel The Outsider and it was very soft
yeah yeah but and also this guy's a lot
like Darth Sidious because he
manipulates the whole political system
and then he makes himself a dictator
that he triggers and then you'll see
what happens all right I will check it
out thank you for the call Sam good to
hear from and by the way the beginning
is really sad David have a great day all
right Sam thank you so much for the call
let me say thanks to three new members
Shannon Starling has signed up on my web
site Kyle clues has signed up on my
website and Nick teal has signed up on
my web site that gets us to 29 new
members this evening that is a that is
just fantastic thank you I really
appreciate it
let me see here Oh are people saying
join pakman.com is down join PAC but
that is just a disaster well can you
imagine if the if the signup website
went down during a stream when people
are just completely titillated by the
possibility of becoming members oh it
does seem to be running slowly it's
running slowly but it is working so I'm
gonna let's see I could probably reset
the entire website but it could take a
little bit of time
yeah all right I apologize about that
folks let me do a couple of other super
chats
khadeem says do you think it's weird
we're protecting the Saudis oil assets
when they were the ones that attacked us
on 9/11 also support Isis yeah listen
I've been talking about our relationship
with the Saudis for ten years and it's
sickening
the tadder says hey David we pretty
massive brexit news across the pond any
comments on it and will you do some
videos on it probably tomorrow probably
tomorrow crypto mojito what do you feel
progressives can do tomorrow about
advancing Medicare for all tomorrow I
think the the most listen I don't know
about tomorrow but I would love to see
Vermont tried this and it failed I would
love to see state single-payer attempted
somewhere and as a test case and I think
it would be really great let's see here
hot mustard gas 20 I just signed up on
your website you already said my name I
liked how you were so chill and honest
thanks for the hard work that you do
thank you I appreciate you signing up
Alex billing are you taking calls from
the UK I you can if you can call the
number you can get on but but the the
system is not limited by who can call in
the number six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty if you want to
make a long-distance phone caller you
Skype by all means Android says David
you know Trump won't be impeached not
the conversation the question is will
the inquiry damage his re-election
chances okay let me do another call here
see who well let's go to someone new
let's go to our caller from the 907
who's been holding for 25 minutes who's
calling today from 907 hey David this is
Rick hey Rick what's going on from
northern New Jersey are doing well
second time calling in live so my
question is if they can investigate
other it matters other than what's going
on in the Ukraine well the top five
matters do you think they should
investigate I don't know about five I
mean the the Trump supporting the Saudi
war in Yemen has got to be up there
arguably impeachable and then Trump
financial crimes is what I would be
looking at I don't even think you need
to touch what has become a toxic
tinderbox of the Russia stuff so are you
thinking about like money laundering
yeah absolutely
okay hello
oh you there yep yep thanks for the Q&A
all right Rick thank you for the call
very much appreciate it
let's go next to our caller from the
five one five area code who's calling
today from five one five five one five
maybe you've got me muted I can't hear
you if you're talking five one five
we'll give you one more opportunity here
all right
no five one five that's disappointing
let's go to oh you know who we haven't
heard from for a while we haven't heard
from oz for awhile
oz what's going on hello hey can you
hear me hey David thanks for taking like
thanks for taking my call my pleasure
I'm Lots cool lots going on there's a
lot I'd love to talk to you about but
yeah I think one major thing is that uh
you know Trump being an impeachable for
his involvement with the Yemen war yeah
they won't touch that because he's not
the only policy major politician and
president that's been in bed with the
Saudis I mean it's been going on for a
long time in this I mean involved Obama
and and the Bush's you know and there's
the whole Carlyle Group with bin Laden
and so I mean I mean with that said I
mean isn't it kind of right to say that
there was somewhat of an inside job with
9/11 I mean because with what the such
heavy involvement with the Saudis but
you know I've always kind of thought the
Saudis were an appendage of no British
and Western intelligence no I would say
that I would not say that 9/11 was an
inside job no well there's there's
elements that that were enabling the
Saudis and they let it happen you know I
don't even know
that I agree with that because a lot of
the individuals were Saudi Saudi but
weren't they trained and radicalized and
associated with groups that that were
not in Saudi Arabia
I know what is it 15 of the hijackers
were Saudi yeah by national and I mean
and the whole hobbyist ideology comes
you know is nurtured from the House of
Saud so I think it's just it's all
proxies yeah I'm not denying that the
I'm not denying the radicalizing
influence of waha busy no I also started
interrupts also you know I really as you
know I used to be involved with the
Baha'i groups and I met a lot of
Iranians and Farsi people and and you
know Iran as far as the the people of a
population not the regime they're
they're way more progressive than the
Saudis are and that's a hillier
absolutely no question and everything
that's happened yeah everything that's
happened with with Iran since since the
CIA overthrew the original regime that
were signing nationalized the oil I mean
yes that's on the CIA I mean the
Institute in the Shah and then the birth
of the Ayatollah is that's all the
fruits of our the CIA's meddling oz let
me answer me did you hear the phone call
from Jimmy from Philly I didn't I was I
just got home from work okay I was gonna
ask what he sounded not he sounded lucid
like not drunk and he said he hasn't
been drinking and I know that previously
you've commented about that so I wanted
to get your thoughts but it sounds like
you missed it well that's great you know
yeah I have I called you a couple months
ago and I I had been sober for a while
but I kind of i relapsed and i've been
drinking quite a bit lately but all you
have I'm so sorry does I did have in my
notes that you were you were doing well
when you called in five five months ago
yeah well I did call you a bunch of
times blacked out and recently and
probably less some rambling drunk
messages
but I'm not drunk right now okay I had
to move from there's one last thing I
wanted to touch on that I had to move
from siesta I'm back in Cincinnati
that's where I'm originally from
Kentucky and I lived out there for eight
years and the wildfires just got too
much just too out of control I had to
evacuate three different times last year
and then I had to evacuate from a little
one this year so I just got tired of it
and I moved back but uh and so I'm
basically starting over and I'm telling
you what there's there's Bernie Sanders
I'm 100% behind him because he's got
he's got the cojones to say he stands
for land reform that's a major issue for
me I've dealt with homelessness and you
know I'm a hard worker I'm a tree
climber and arborist and Forester and uh
it's I'm basically starting all over
again
and I think there's you know back in the
day there used to be inmates used to be
given property when they were released
from prison you know so they could work
the land when and have something to go
back to and that doesn't happen where
there's enough federal land that every
homeless person could be given an acre
and it wouldn't even make a dent in the
federal land and people I think anyone
who's willing to work the land should be
given the opportunity to to live on the
land and work on it and I think that's a
major that that's um that's why you know
I'm really behind Bernie now on that
because he's got he's the only one will
ever say anything like that so yeah I
really appreciate the call David all
right thank you hope um I hope you're
able to get back is it is the phrase on
the wagon or is it yet to be on the
wagon is not to be drinking right yeah I
wish there was more secular you know
recovery you know they push though a lot
of the religious stuff in the recovery
and it turns a lot of people off yeah
the best set to hear you're not doing so
well lately let me say thanks to Katrina
frul on and brick BRE at Brett Brianne
Brianne Lowe Priore new members number
30 and 31 of the evening so we have not
only do we have open phones I'll be
doing another stream tomorrow as well
let me do a couple of super chats
Jessica Ann says David what's your
opinion on burn
democracy day bill to make Election Day
a national holiday thank you I love that
painting behind you yeah just a poster I
got in Paris burnt so I'm fine with
Election Day being a national holiday I
think there might be more benefit to
moving Election Day to a weekend and
I've read views about doing one either
or both but I think we need to do
anything we can to increase voter
turnout for sure a tea class official
says not the san antonio troll i don't
even see the sanon let me see if I have
any San Antonio callers on the line
there is a sin you know let's just see
who it is let's just go to two one zero
two one zero is a tinderbox of an area
code for us
who's calling today from two one zero
which I presume is a caller from San
Antonio yes it is oh yeah you don't
sound like the San Antonio troll no I'm
not I'm T club's official hi good how
are you I'm great yeah thanks for taking
my call
I had um I had a question about kind of
about abortion okay so I've I'm kind of
falling off the the pro-choice side a
little bit and I'm a progressive liberal
like you and I've been watching the show
and it's very informative so thank you
and keep up the good work
thank you but you know I think I think
the particular arguments right now about
it being the whole woman's body woman's
choice thing I don't think that's a
particularly good argument that we
should be making as liberals or anyone
on the left because I mean fact is just
factually untrue
I mean whatever you want to call it
whether you want to call it a baby or
whether you want to say it's a fetus I
mean it is a biologically different a
different entity inside the womb of the
mother and so when it's clear that you
did you know the DNA is a different
person and well if you
you know and I think when do we call it
a person and in in the pregnancy and at
a certain point if we do call it person
should everything be illegal after that
it should abortion to be legal after you
know a certain point and I just don't
think that the you know I don't think
the her body her choice thing is
carrying you know listen here I don't
agree I don't I don't agree with your
particular disassembling of that
particular defense but I do agree with
you that that's never for me been like
the strongest defense so generally
speaking I don't think that it is the
best crutch for the left to the
pro-choice movement to stand on well
sorry but it is it is hello okay that's
weird
alright I guess we lost them
Jenna kill pop asks do you prefer
signing up on patreon or on your site I
would say my site because we keep more
of the money so all of these different
methods for supporting the show patreon
YouTube subscription YouTube paid
subscription any of them they keep
anywhere from like five to thirty
percent of your payment which is just
cuckoo on my website we just paid two
point nine percent to process credit and
debit cards and we keep ninety seven
point one percent so that's always the
preferred method and on that note Aiden
basher has signed up on my website and
Aiden his new new member number 32 of
the evening and we retain ninety seven
point one percent of every payment that
Aiden makes because that's just how it
works
hot mustard gas has signed up on YouTube
David Corona sends a 999 super chat JC
sends a ten dollar super jet saying if
Democrats win the presidency hold the
house and when the Senate but short of
sixty can we pass a carbon tax through
reconciliation if so should we Senate
will not be won by Democrats in 2020
unfortunately Pat Doyle and art Flores
and two dollars and a dollar ninety nine
art asking David is illegal immigration
a
Dilys crime it is there there is listen
putting politics aside that is not a yes
or no answer that is something that has
to be discussed in in a number of
different ways but the victims are not
the ones that the right would have you
believe they are Jimmy from Philly says
tell oz to get some LSD boob boy says
tax cuts did help working people make
America great again Dems are a joke hope
it was worth $2 to you in Dinny Jarvis
ends $1 super chat t clause official
says sorry Bri broke off thanks and hope
to talk again yeah I don't know we just
seem to have lost you that was weird
let's go next to our caller from where
do we want to go next what about the six
one two area code six one two has been
holding for a long time what's going on
six one two this is Alex I'm calling
from Minnesota how are you hey Alex good
how are you good
just a quick question so how does the
since the formal in Pisan process is
kind of started now how does it kind of
vary from a practice and standpoint from
the the previous investigations that
were going on the Russian related ones
that is well this is just that was a
Special Counsel investigation this is an
impeachment inquiry and remember that it
this is just the inquiry this is not the
process of arguing for impeachment
subsequently to be voted on by the
Senate this this is just the inquiry
that's all we've got so far yeah
absolutely but more specifically does
beginning the formal impeachment process
grant the house and the additional
investigative powers you know
to the extent that they have subpoena
powers already I don't believe or at
least I've not read that starting what a
formal impeachment inquiry grants them
more powers although hopefully it would
make those who were subpoenaed both for
documents or their testimony less
willing to ignore the subpoenas if that
makes sense but I'm not aware of any
special powers that the house gets
right I wasn't just sure if it was you
know codified anywhere that it was
actually you know granted them anything
else yeah yeah otherwise only other
question would be do you like beer yes I
do I prefer microbrews white ales and
Belgian style beers any anything in
particular I don't know I mean my go-to
when I don't know what's going on is
allagash white alright I can take
Michael alright I hope I didn't
filibuster you there I just cut right to
the cut right to the chase let me say
thanks to Karen Lee Johnston who has
just signed up on my website as well as
Aaron Richland I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly and Jennifer Stewart
three more members which gets us to 35
for the evening I think our record right
now is 44 we had that last about two
weeks ago during the democratic debate
livestream Andrew Hollis is asking via
super chat whether I plan to speak with
sam harris again not no specific plan
right now but certainly open to it let's
go next to let's go to our caller from
the three six zero area code three six
we get a lot of calls from three six
zero but I never remember where it where
it's from where is three six zero from
it's from Washington alright what's
going on who's this there's Nathan hey
Nathan what's up i I was just wondering
how do they do these polls who who
regulates them where do they come from
are they reliable like which one what's
the poet was an example the list that
you showed earlier of all the different
polling places yep so you just click go
and you can see I mean let's just take a
look at you know this latest one that's
from Emerson if you click on it usually
somewhere on the page and I'm doing this
right now you will see okay so so
Emerson is the place that did it first
of all and they'll tell you the
methodology so this one was done during
a three-day period it was done under the
supervision of a particular assistant
professor it was a sample of only
registered voters a thousand nine
of them they have a credibility interval
that they use which is similar to a
margin of error which it tells you it
tells you that they've waited the data
by ethnicity age mode gender and region
based on turnout modeling from 2016
right so you you can look at each of
these and then it says this was
collected using an interactive voice
response system of landlines and an
online panel provided by Amazon Turk so
that's this particular poll and you can
just look at each of them and look at
what the methodology was is there any
government regulation on them or
interaction with the government I I
don't know whether you as a pulsar have
to be registered with the government in
some way I don't believe you do I think
it's more a matter of you know if if
Breitbart does a poll versus if morning
consult does one maybe we trust one more
than the other on the basis of
partisanship but I'm not aware of any
government regulation per se yeah like
Fox News would be really hard to trust
that one yeah I mean let's just look at
what it says as far let's pull up the
Fox News one and see what they say about
methodology so Fox says a random
national sample of a thousand eight
registered voters it was heavily
weighted to cell phones versus landlines
and they used a probability
proportionate to size method which means
phone numbers for each state are
proportional to the number of voters in
each stage so I mean listen you know
that it's not necessarily a bad poll I
mean I I I reason to believe Rasmussen
tends to be more skewed than the Fox
News polls to be perfectly honest well
interesting yeah well thank you I'll go
on and a look at that I appreciate
you're getting these live streams out I
try and catch them every time thank you
my pleasure Nathan I appreciate your
support thank you so much let me say
thanks to Ryan breaker who has also
signed up on my website and his new
member number 36 of the evening
appreciate that
a couple other super chats to deal with
here let's see
Sophia asks hey David sorry if you
already talked about this and I missed
it I'm
what your thoughts are on the China and
Russia soy import deal I've not talked
about that and I don't know enough about
it to comment but I will research it
Dolores
Tapia with a $10 super chat Thank You
dusty Dark Horse says if you ever get
the chance try street fight a red ale
made right here in Montana I tend not to
like red ales but I'm willing to try it
Benjamin Glatt says I missed your
response to the abortion caller but I
want to point out you can't take organs
from a body without prior permission
okay Yosef kheh
says David what's the point of
impeachment if no Republicans will go
along with it doesn't this hurt us in
2020 it may hurt but the idea would be
that this gets out the wrongdoing of
Trump in a way that helps Democrats in
2020 at least that's the gist Miz ek
sent a 400 H what is I don't know what
HUF is what currency is HUF 400 HUF to
USD Hungarian forints it's a dollar and
32 cents okay six one seven area code
please answer let's see if I find six
one seven here I don't know how you're
calling from six one seven if your
international button let's see six one
seven yeah I don't see anybody from six
one seven unfortunately so I'm not able
to go to that Alex Billings says if
anyone is in pro-choice I encourage you
to watch philosophy tube on the issue
philosophy tube is really good and I
interviewed him last week beta ray tasty
says there are many simple
misconceptions about single single-payer
health care that take me 15 seconds to
clear up if they're so simple why don't
they go away because the right needs
them to keep single payer from becoming
a reality Jay Nelson says just wanted to
send a little support I noticed your
videos being phased out in my youtube
algorithm it's not just huge I it is a
lot of people experiencing that sue
Coolio which area of Boston are you from
David I realize you're a fellow
Bostonian I work at Tufts Medical if
you've heard of it yes I'm actually not
from Boston I'm from Argentina but now
based in Boston
Martin 'its says our family courts are
broken no money for basic rights that is
a major major problem no doubt about it
let's go next to our caller from the 972
area code who has been holding for 45
minutes I appreciate your persistence 9
7 2 well yes that is you oh hey I'm
sorry you said your name is Ashton
Sebastian Sebastian I've got a cousin
named Sebastian lovely name oh thank you
thank you anyways my question was to
quickly David was that if you somehow
got the ability to make a law team are
to be passed and to be the official law
what would you do what wouldn't he had
the ability to I mean what when you say
a law do you what is what are you
include I could I say well I would just
make single-payer health care the law
well you know like I guess like broad
strokes I mean one type of change if you
try to would you try to initiate you
know what you were trying to make
permanent in the in the country right
now I would try to pass a law that would
pierce the corporate aqua see lobbyist
money controls politics industrial
complex I would try to do something
related to that mmm you think it's a
lobbyist that's a big issue with that or
it's just the money you going between
them it's a lot of different things
that's why I'd have to think about what
one law would most effectively start to
pierce that but it would be something to
work on that issue oh okay alright
that's what I was just wondering oh and
do you know well you know since you
actually work on different forms of
media radio TV and YouTube as well yeah
why do you think that YouTube is so
focused on trying to become a television
station when it seems like the reason
why people are going to YouTube is to
get away from that yeah I mean it's just
they've calculated that this is the the
business model that they want to be
pushing period and you know it's clearly
making YouTube something
very different than what it was at the
beginning and it's sad and it hurts
shows like mine but alas it's their
business decision to make if they want
to make it for sure
ok I was just just wondering what your
take on that since you did and all kind
question what hair product do you use
man it always looks good I use it's
called American Crew fibre I believe is
the name of it all right it's not the
cheapest stuff but it's solid it's what
I'm with I've been with them for a
decade they've never sponsored anything
although they should quite frankly and
it's a it's an excellent product get
that get that David pack and seal of
approval on it absolutely absolutely all
right thanks for the call very much
appreciate it all right thank you okay
take care Michael Blasio says what are
your thoughts on genetics and I hear I
have numerous long-form videos about
that
Aaron right schlund says kudos for
saying my name correctly no one does I
think I might have just mispronounced it
the second time
Sabrina Zafar says I know it's
unpredictable but how would a successful
impeachment affect 2020 well a
successful successful impeachment would
make the winner of the 2020 election
whoever wins the Democratic nomination
that that's the the big picture of it
and exactly what constitutes successful
impeachment depends on who you talk to
you but removal of Trump is not going to
happen in in my view let me say welcome
and thank you to Melissa
Heaphy or hey fee who is new member
number 37 of the evening and on that
note that's gonna wrap tonight's live
stream sorry to everybody I wasn't able
to get to but I'm committing to do
another livestream tomorrow night it'll
be on twitch twitch TV slash David
Pakman follow me on Twitch subscribe
with twitch prime if you have Amazon
Prime it'll cost you nothing and I'll
see you tomorrow night on twitch for
another live stream